the bike is made of chromoly steel which
is pound-for-pound stronger than
standard steel to prepare the bike's
tubular parts including the frame a
worker cuts steel tube with the
horizontal bandsaw into specific length
pieces
[Music]
he then clamps certain frame pieces into
a milling machine which will cut a curve
into one or both ends depending on the
pieces location in the final assembly
once all the frame parts are ready
a welder clamps them in a fixture which
correctly positions them for assembly he
works with the welding torch in one hand
and a rod a filler metal in the other
the torch melts adjacent tubes at their
meeting point so that they fuse together
to put the bicycle together the worker
suspends the frame in an assembly stand
and then inserts the bottom bracket
which will ultimately support the bikes
drivetrain system the bikes fenders are
made of sheet steel that's shaped with
pressure applying rollers
the rear fender attaches to the rear
drop belt and defender mounts at two
other locations on the frames for
triangle he screws the cargo rack to
middle and rear rack supports then he
inserts and bolts the rear wheel into
the rear drop out the wheel hub has
three built-in gears the hub and rim are
made of aluminum which is lightweight
and doesn't rust the wheel spokes are
stainless steel next the worker installs
the drivetrain system
inserting the crank arms already mounted
to the chain ring onto the bottom
bracket he tightens the bolts securely
with a torque wrench
workers then insert the fork into the
bottom of the head tube and
chrome-plated steel handlebars into the
top mount the front fender and front
wheel then install the pedals final seat
chain and chain guard with the gear
shifter and front brake lever on the
handlebars this steel bicycle is ready
to hit the road
[Music]